[Music]
Abby Lee Miller gets pampered after
prison on Thursday the former Dance Moms
star was spotted tending to her nails a
pampered hand spa in Los Angeles he or
she is getting a mani and don't worry
she got a petty - if you look closely
you'll notice
Abby is rocking a black t-shirt that
features her dance company's logo and an
eyewitness tells us she was in full hair
and makeup and looked very healthy the
51 year old was just released from the
Federal Correctional Complex in
Victorville California earlier this week
Abby was originally sentenced to one
year and one day in federal prison last
July after pleading guilty to bankruptcy
fraud that same month
Abby told et that she planned to use the
time behind bars to focus on herself and
I've always put everybody else's child
first before my own house before my own
outfit before my own time frame you know
everybody else was dressed and out the
door and looking perfect and I was
running around trying to find a clean
towel to take a shower with so I think
this will be a little me time
it seems Abby is focusing on me time in
her freedom to